welcome back everybody the family of Rex
huerman held a press conference Friday
expressing their shock and trying to
process their new reality that the
lifelong family man that they knew is
suspected of being a serial killer the
life of Manhattan architect Rex humerman
has been turned upside down since he was
arrested and charged with the murders of
three women he's also suspected in a
fourth all four women were found wrapped
in burlap on Long Island's Gilgo Beach
right across the bay from the suspect's
home but it was DNA DNA evidence that
pointed investigators in human's
direction as the Quest for evidence
continues a seemingly well put together
family is falling apart prosecutors
revealed that the suspect lived a double
life using burner phones and email
accounts to meet escorts and search for
child pornography all while living under
the same roof as his wife daughter and
stepson pyramid's estranged wife Asa
elarap has since filed for divorce and
has publicly denied any involvement in
her husband's alleged crimes attorneys
for ellerop and the rest of her family
shared more details at Friday's press
conference ellerup has cancer and her
attorney said she will soon run out of
money to cover her treatments the
family's home also remains severely
damaged from the recent raid by
investigators an attorney for humerman's
children announced the family's next
steps
this case is going to be a very long
time in the making and through that
process obviously we've talked about
in the past few days that the law
requires them in order to preserve those
legal rights and remedies to file
certain legal documents at certain
intervals if they don't do that they
will have waived those rights in the
public forum so we are at this point
announcing that the children
on her behalf are going to be protecting
those legal rights and remedies by
filing what's called a notice of claim
that notice of claim is going to be
filed within the next 30 days and that
obviously is a legal prerequisite to
filing a lawsuit and it has to be done
because otherwise those rights are
waived and that's what's going to happen
when it happens obviously we'll let you
all know we'll let you folks know what
the content of it is but that's the
announcement that we have to make in
closing I like to Echo my colleagues
statements at this time the family again
requests truly and honestly that their
rights and Liberties have to be
protected and a part of that again is
that the focus is on their basic needs
their food their water their shelter
their clothing okay and and that's
they're Paramount concern right now it
is those basic human needs that all of
us have that have been ripped apart from
them so we ask you again please respect
their privacy please know that they're
going through a horrific emotional time
that none of us could imagine and let
the legal process run its for us okay
there's a few things I want to break
down here for first is it normal for a
home or a property to be destroyed
during the raid because he's innocent
right now he's innocent until proven
guilty I mean it's not just him his
family right far more innocent right
than he is they have no allegations yes
unfortunately this is a common
occurrence and a common conversation I
have with parents and landlords who have
people who have their their tenants
search where their home property and
even Vehicles can be destroyed and the
thing that most disturbing to me is
Vehicles when they search a vehicle like
for example pull up on a panel of a door
to search and see the drugs inside they
just need to make sure the car is
operable when it's given back the panel
of a door is not a part of the operation
the car so people are left with parts of
the car missing or left open like you
got to figure it out and does the city
ever pay for it I mean I know she said
that his her attorney said they're going
to file a notice of claim in
anticipation of a lawsuit do they ever
get any money back for this so that
really depends on what county and what
state you're in sometimes if you ask
they'll pay but if you want to force
them to do so it is very difficult
there's usually two different Avenues
and both of them often lead in a dead
end some people go under the Fifth
Amendment and the taking clause and they
say Hey you took something you damaged
my property and you didn't give me Fair
compensation well the state or the city
will come back around and say well it's
not for public use and when people agree
what does that mean well in the taking
Clause if the state or the government
takes something for you for public use
they're supposed to give you fair
compensation couldn't they say they're
doing a public benefit by getting a
skill you know doing a public
investigation and that's what I say as
well the public benefit is that you're
taking this criminal off the streets but
no they still courts still get them
around that oftentimes the courts say
this is a tort that you want to file
against the city but if you file a tort
against the city you have to show that
that search warrant was unreasonable
show me how you're going to show that
this search word was unreasonable we
were talking about the Gilgo Beach
murders and you're trying to get a
connection between three women that were
dead and the man in that house very
difficult real quick this notice of
claim what is it how does it work is it
going to be successful at all oh notice
of claim is just letting the the state
computroller or whoever may be based in
your account you know within 90 days if
it's here in New York which it is that
we are going to sue you and we're going
to ask for this it's just you can't sue
the state or the county of the city
without letting them know first well my
heart goes out to the family
um and I didn't know that she was sick
that's equally as difficult to think
about so I'm glad she has legal
representation because this is a serious
issue and I'm curious to see what might
be the end result if she'll get any
money back or any compensation based on
what happened all right when we come
back an Iowa sex offender stands trial
and the murder of a young girl family
ties between the victim and defendant
and what a police Sergeant revealed on
the stand
foreign
we finished Today's Show with a recap
out of Iowa in the trial of Defending
Henry Dinkins he's the man accused of
kidnapping and ultimately killing a 10
year old girl found shot to death in a
pond in July of 2020 breesia Tyrell and
her brother were staying with Dinkins
and his girlfriend overnight in the Iowa
City of Davenport Dinkins is the father
of Brie Asia's half-brother and the
kid's mother told reporters that neither
She nor bre Asia felt unsafe around him
but at some point during the night it is
believed that Dinkins took briasia from
the apartment and killed her her
disappearance prompted a massive search
that lasted for eight months and then in
March of 2021 fishermen spotted the
missing girl's body in a pond about 25
miles away from Davenport at that time
Dinkins was actually locked up on an
unrelated charge you see it turns out
he's a sex offender who had been
released early from prison but he was
required to register police say he
didn't do that so they arrested him then
when Brie Asia's remains were found they
charged him with kidnapping and murder
now this is a unique case because
Dinkins opted for a bench trial this
means that a jury will not be involved
and the defendant's Fate will ultimately
be decided by a judge the prosecution
gave their opening statement Thursday
while the defense opted to wait until
their case begins on Friday the judge
heard several prosecution witnesses
including a Davenport Police Sergeant
during his testimony both parties
brought up interesting facts in the case
uh we were able to observe Henry
dinkin's maroon Chevy Impala in the
parking lot of Walmart and then further
we observed Henry dinkin's walk from his
Chevy Impala into the Walmart
and then what did he do there within the
store he purchased two bottles of Clorox
bleach okay what time of the morning
would that have occurred and what date
just after 7 A.M on the morning of July
10th and is that before he's made the
telephone call to Aisha at 808 a.m to
report to her that briation is missing
yes it's before then okay we don't have
any blood of barasia Tyrell anywhere in
this case do we no
we don't have any blood in that Impala
do we none
see I think that part's big if they
catch him buying bleach and they don't
have the blood I guess the assumption is
he used the bleach to bleach the blood
away now yeah but you can bleach blood
stains away not necessarily blood away
it's one of those True Crime things you
mean he covered it up and didn't commit
the crime no no so if if there was blood
here and we took bleach right or let's
let's get one of these right Michael
Bryant we'll do a little demonstration
blood here get bleached we can get this
nice and white but it doesn't mean that
someone can't test this and still get
blood from it so if you say we didn't
see blood and there was bleach used and
that makes sense but if you tested you
should still see it even though you
bleached it so I think that's a bit of a
red herring for me the defense makes
more sense of saying hey there's a shirt
with blood there was an ax with blood
there was blood on other things so why
not clean it all up the fact that
there's no blood inside and the bleach I
think is a bit of a red herring but I
think it's interesting nonetheless yeah
what do you make of that that her blood
wasn't found on those items she was
killed not in the car she was never
brought back into the car maybe she was
killed at the pond and then dumped there
or they you're the fence the car had
nothing to do with she was never in the
car to begin with there was no foul play
in the car depends on what facts you
want to lead with talk about the car so
the only evidence that breesia was in
the car was from this eyewitness saying
that they saw her outside of the Chevy
Impala at night is that strong enough
for the prosecution
I think it's good but I think the
defense can really work with it because
you go okay what time of night was it
it's like 11 o'clock at night when this
when this witness saw it how far were
you how good is your vision you're
wearing glasses you're not wearing
glasses did you just wake up were you
drinking that night that kind of death
by a thousand paper cuts of questions to
see how substantial that is and then
also you saw her outside the car but did
you ever see her go in the car because
simply seeing her outside doesn't
necessarily mean that she went with him
maybe like many children they run out
and see daddy or mommy or stepdad or
whoever it is and they said oh go back
inside Daddy just going for a ride
you don't know so you think there's
avenues for the defense we will see
Brian great to see you great talking
with you as always thanks for everybody
thanks everybody for joining us here on
Long crime daily we're going to see you
next time as we discuss Justice and
America